Jealousy, ego, and not knowing what a wolverine
is — these actors turned down movie
parts for some peculiar reasons.
In November of 2021, "Fast & Furious" veteran
Vin Diesel took to Instagram to plead with
Dwayne Johnson to participate in the 10th
installment of the long-running franchise,
"Fast X." Johnson had previously stated that he
would not be returning, which many believe is
due to a feud between the actors that has
spanned more than six years and counting.
However, Diesel still tried to seemingly
guilt trip the actor in front of his 82
million followers on social media, claiming
that his children still refer to Johnson as
"Uncle Dwayne" and that Johnson's character of
Luke Hobbs could never be recast or replaced.
Not long afterward, Johnson sat down with CNN
and set the record straight. "The Rock" told
the world that he and Diesel had come to
an agreement in private. Long story short:
the former wrestler would not
be returning to the franchise.
"Your mistake is thinking you've
got a goddamn choice, boy."
Johnson said that he was "very surprised"
by Diesel's Instagram post, expressing
his disappointment in the actor's
clear "manipulation." He continued —
"I didn't like that he brought
up his children in the post,
as well as Paul Walker's
death. Leave them out of it."
It's safe to say that Diesel's impassioned request
didn't make much of a difference in Johnson's
decision. Despite his frustration at the very
public way that it was handled, Johnson maintains
that he will always cheer for the success of
the "Fast & Furious" movies and their cast.
"A League of Their Own" is
a fictionalized portrayal of
the All-American Girls Professional
Baseball League and its best team,
the Rockford Peaches. Debra Winger was
originally cast in the lead role, and she
spent months training with the Chicago Cubs in
order to increase her authenticity. However, the
moment that Madonna was added to the project, the
"Terms of Endearment" actress was out the door.
Winger believed that, rather than
"A League of Their Own" being the
historically empowering story it was meant
to be, the Queen of Pop's involvement
would drive the film in a different
direction. She told The Telegraph —
"I think [her] acting career
has spoken for itself."
"And what am I supposed to do, huh?
Go back to taxi dancing? Ten cents so
some slob can sweat gin all over me?"
Despite the film's eventual positive reception,
the actress had a few choice words to
say about the final product — like her
claim that Madonna lacked the proper
preparation. Winger told Vanity Fair —
"As entertaining as [the final film]
was, you don't walk away going, 'Wow,
those women did that.' You
kind of go, 'Is that true?'"
In 2013, production for the Natalie Portman
Western film "Jane Got a Gun" was about to
kick off when it hit a major snag. After a
three-day standoff over delays and control of
the final cut with producer Scott Steindorff,
director Lynne Ramsay stepped away from the
project the day that production was supposed
to begin, leaving a chaotic environment behind.
Ramsay's choice to quit the film ultimately
led to the departure of cinematographer
Darius Khondji and actor Jude Law, who was
originally set to play the movie's antagonist.
Several unnamed sources claim that Law had
admitted to only signing up for the project for
the opportunity to work alongside Ramsay, although
he hasn't confirmed this himself. Regardless,
without her in the director's chair, he seemingly
had no interest in continuing with the project.
Law was later replaced by Bradley Cooper, who
also ended up dropping out due to scheduling
conflicts. The movie would finally
hit theaters with Ewan McGregor in
the villainous role and Gavin O'Connor in
the director's chair. Partially as a result
of the cast and crew controversy, "Jane
Got a Gun" was a box office flop. Today,
it's primarily remembered as a low point
for the production company that financed it.
Steve McQueen spent the '60s and
'70s enjoying the fruits of stardom,
appearing as the leading man in
countless films that would go on
to become classics. Over three decades after
his death, McQueen still holds the moniker
of the "king of cool" thanks to his long
list of interesting hobbies and talents.
During casting for the Western classic
"Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid,"
McQueen accepted the role of Sundance
after reading through the script. However,
he wound up stepping away from the role over
disagreements with his co-star, Paul Newman.
McQueen's undeniable star power led him
to refuse second billing to another actor,
despite the fact that Newman was arguably
more famous at the time. The role later
went to Robert Redford, in what has become
one of his career defining performances.
"Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid"
went on to garner widespread acclaim,
soaring to the top of the charts as the biggest
box office draw for two weeks after its release.
In 2019, Charlize Theron sat down with Andy Cohen
on "Watch What Happens Live" and discussed the
topic of ageism in Hollywood. When Theron was
asked by a fan why she reportedly turned down
the monumental role of Wonder Woman, the "Mad
Max: Fury Road" star set the record straight
by sharing the real story. Theron explained
that she was discussing possible involvement
in the film when someone informed her that she
would actually be taking on a supporting role.
"I'm not familiar with it, I
don't really know, like — I mean,
what does Wonder Woman do? And my — this person
said, 'No, it's for Wonder Woman's mom.'"
Theron naturally turned the role down,
and seems to be able to laugh about it
now. She called it a "defining
moment" in her Hollywood career,
in which she had crossed over to a completely
new category of roles without even realizing it.
You might remember Ja Rule from his
hip-hop heyday in the 2000s — or maybe
you know him as the co-founder of the
disastrous Fyre Festival. Regardless,
in the summer of 2002, Ja Rule was riding
a career high — he was one of the biggest
rappers on the planet and secured that
year's Billboard Award for top rap album.
Ja Rule had a minor part in "The Fast and the
Furious," the first film in what would become
a massive franchise. He was later approached to
be upgraded to a starring role for the sequel,
"2 Fast 2 Furious," along with
a cozy half-a-million-dollar
payday. Surprisingly the rapper was
reluctant to participate in the film.
Rule allegedly acted like a bit of a prima
donna during the casting process. In 2015, "2
Fast" director John Singleton explained that the
rapper's ego had become inflated. He elaborated —
"He wouldn't return calls. I went to the
studio to go see him [...] He was kinda
playing me to the side and I was
like, 'What? What is this s---?'"
When talking to MTV about the ordeal,
Rule pointed to his desire to make a
more serious name for himself
in the acting world, saying —
"I just felt it wasn't the best move for me as
far as what I want to do in Hollywood right now."
The frustrated director eventually reached out to
Ludacris to create a new role in place
of Rule's, and the rest is history.
"Brokeback Mountain" — the Western
romantic drama starring Heath Ledger
and Jake Gyllenhaal — is a beautiful
movie, and it's tough to imagine any
other actors portraying the cowboy lovers at
its center. However, if you ask Mark Wahlberg,
he'll tell you that he was considered for one of
the starring roles, but wound up turning it down.
In a 2007 interview, Wahlberg revealed
his reasoning for declining the role,
telling Premiere Magazine —
"I read 15 pages of the script and got a little
creeped out. It was very graphic, descriptive —
the spitting on the hand, getting ready to
do the thing [...] it's just not my deal."
Wahlberg may not be the most reliable
narrator — after all, he's also claimed
that he would've single-handedly stopped
9/11. Perhaps he's telling the truth about
having had the opportunity to star in Ang
Lee's 2005 classic, but it wouldn't be the
first time Wahlberg has exaggerated a little
bit during a conversation with the media.
Many people point to Marky Mark's strict
Catholic beliefs as a possible reason
for his discomfort in playing
a man attracted to other men.
Wahlberg has claimed that being a Catholic
is the "most important aspect" of his life,
and his recent pivot to faith-based media like
2022's "Father Stu" is further evidence of that.
The National Enquirer even once reported that
Wahlberg's priest, James Flavin, always has the
final say in whether or not the actor should
accept a role. An unnamed insider shared —
"[Wahlberg] never makes a final
decision on a starring role until
Father Flavin gives his OK. Mark says
he owes his career to Father Flavin."
It seems that Wahlberg may
not have made the right call,
as far as money is concerned. The legendary
performances of Ledger and Gyllenhaal
earned "Brokeback Mountain" three Academy
Awards and $178 million at the box office.
It's hard to imagine anyone other than Hugh
Jackman playing the mutant superhero Wolverine,
but Russell Crowe almost took the role for
himself. Crowe was the first choice to play
Logan in 2000's "X-Men," but the legendary
actor turned down the role over fears of
being typecast. What type was Crowe worried about
being cast as? Why, a wolf enthusiast, of course.
Given that Crowe's iconic character of Maximus in
the film "Gladiator" is associated with wolves,
the actor was concerned about becoming
Hollywood's go-to "Mr. Wolf," according
to News.com.au. He didn't seem to know or
care that wolverines aren't wolves at all.
Given the ongoing multi-billion-dollar franchise
that was born from the first "X-Men" film,
Crowe losing out on the role of a lifetime
seems like a huge misstep that could have
led to years of regret. But in a 2019 interview
on "The Howard Stern Show," Crowe expressed his
respect for Jackman's performance and
showed that he had no hard feelings.
"I wouldn't have carried it through with the
grace and the, the direction that Hugh gave it."
In fact, it was Crowe who recommended
Jackman — a relatively unknown actor
at the time — to replace him in the role.
Will Smith has appeared in his fair share of
headlines over the years. Whether it's the Oscar
slap heard 'round the world or his complicated
relationship with his wife Jada, the actor is
pretty familiar with being in the spotlight. Back
when prepping began for Quentin Tarantino's 2012
film "Django Unchained," Will Smith was offered
the opportunity to play the titular character of
Django, which would eventually go to Jamie Foxx.
In 2013, Smith sat down with Entertainment Weekly
and explained his choice to turn down the
role. His explanation was short and sweet:
"Django wasn't the lead."
In Smith's eyes, King Schultz, the
dentist-turned-bounty-hunter played
by Christoph Waltz, is the true lead of the film
— after all, Schultz gets to kill the bad guy.
However, in a much later 2016 interview with
The Hollywood Reporter, Smith claimed that he
turned down the role due to the overwhelming
use of violence in the story. He explained —
"I wanted to make the greatest love story that
African Americans had ever
seen from American cinema."
Essentially, Smith didn't want to have to rely
on violence as the answer to racial conflict.